- [Woman] I'd like to have your response
on what seems to be
a changing in our history
with so many statues
being removed and taken out of view
and it's like we want to disassociate
ourself with all of this history.
And yet, that's part of our history
whether we like it or not
that's been there
and I would like to have your
thoughts on it.
- I mean obviously,
that is a very controversial topic today.
My view about it
is that it seems
entirely justifiable
to me that statues
which quite obviously
would give offense to particular
communities should not
stand without context.
So what I mean by that
is that statues for example,
of the kind in the South
that we've been talking about
I understand why some of these statues
would be removed.
But I wouldn't wish to see them destroyed.
I would wish to see them put
into some kind of environment
that provides context
that recognizes that they are part
of the history of the United States.
Because the controversy
is not something that is just from today
these are things
which have been controversial
and are born out of controversy
throughout the entire history
of the United States very often.
So, in some ways, maybe my response
is precisely that of a historian
that we don't want to wipe these things
from the record
but we need to understand
them in the context of history
to contextualize them.
Because I think ultimately
by contextualizing them
we understand them and then we are able,
as a society, we are able to move forward.